let's say we have a pure sample of
phosphorus pentachloride and we add the
pcl5 to a previously evacuated flask at
500 kelvin
and let's say the initial pressure of
the pcl5 is
1.6
atmospheres some of the pcl5 is going to
turn into pcl3 and cl2
once equilibrium is reached the total
pressure let's say is measured to be
2.35 atmospheres
our goal is to calculate the equilibrium
partial pressures of these three
substances so pcl5 pcl3 and cl2 and from
those equilibrium partial pressures we
can also calculate the kp value for this
reaction at 500 kelvin
to help us find the equilibrium partial
pressures we're going to use an ice
table where i stands for the initial
partial pressure in atmospheres c is the
change in partial pressure and e stands
for the equilibrium partial pressure we
already know we're starting with a
partial pressure of 1.66 atmospheres for
pcl5
and if we assume that the reaction
hasn't started yet we're starting with
zero for our partial pressures of pcl3
and cl2
some of the pcl5 is going to decompose
and since we don't know how much we're
going to call that amount x so we're
going to write minus x here since we're
going to lose some pcl5
next we need to look at mole ratios so
the mole ratio of pcl5 to pcl3 is one to
one so for losing x for pcl5 we must be
gaining x for pcl3 the same idea with
cl2 the coefficient in the balanced
equation is a one so if we're losing x
for pcl5 that means we're gaining x for
cl2
therefore the equilibrium partial
pressure for pcl5 would be
1.66 minus x
the equilibrium partial pressure for
pcl3 would be 0 plus x which is just x
and the equilibrium partial pressure for
cl2 would be 0 plus x which is also x
to figure out what x is we're going to
use dalton's law and dalton's law says
that the total pressure of a mixture of
gases is equal to the sum of the
individual partial pressures of the
gases in the mixture
so we said that the total pressure of
all the gases at equilibrium is equal to
2.35
atmospheres so we can plug that into
dalton's law and then we can take the
equilibrium partial pressures from our
ice table and plug those into dalton's
law as well so we're going to plug in
1.66 minus x for the equilibrium partial
pressure of pcl5
x for the equilibrium partial pressure
of pcl3 and x for the equilibrium
partial pressure of pcl2
so let's plug in 1.66
minus x
and then we have plus x and plus x
and let's solve for x notice how we have
a minus x and a plus x so that cancels
out so we simply subtract 1.66 from
2.35 and we find that x is equal to 0.69
so if x is equal to 0.69 the equilibrium
partial pressure of cl2 is 0.69
atmospheres
and equilibrium the equilibrium partial
pressure pcl3 is also
0.69 atmospheres
and 1.66 minus 0.69 gives us the
equilibrium partial pressure of pcl5
and that's equal to 0.97
atmospheres
now that we have our equilibrium partial
pressures for all three gases we can
calculate the value for the equilibrium
constant for this reaction at 500 kelvin
first we need to write an equilibrium
constant expression so we would write kp
is equal to
and for our products we have pcl3 so
this would be the partial pressure of
pcl3
times the partial pressure of our other
product which is cl2 so let's put in
there the partial pressure of cl2
and all of that is divided by
the partial pressure of pcl5 so this
would be the partial pressure of pcl5
next we plug in our equilibrium partial
pressures so the equilibrium partial
pressure of pcl3 is 0.69 the equilibrium
partial pressure of cl2 is also 0.69 and
the equilibrium partial pressure of pcl5
is 0.97 once we plug our numbers in and
we solve we get that kp is equal to
0.49 at 500 kelvin